okay let's talk about david culley the
new head coach you've known him for a
long time he was the receiver's coach at
texas a m 91-93 i believe he's been a
long-time receivers coach he was
assistant head coach with the kansas
city chiefs and andy reid he was with
andy reid because somebody was telling
me today oh david collins just bounced
all over the places are you kidding me
he was with andy reid for 18 freaking
years from 1999 through 2016
18 seasons with reed trusted enough to
be assistant head coach trusted by john
harbaugh to be assistant head coach in
baltimore he was quarterback's coach of
the bills for two years 2017 and 2018
the playoff year with tyrod taylor he
was quarterback's coach 2018 the first
year with josh allen he was
quarterback's coach i'd love to know why
he decided to first step into that after
all the time with reid and then
exit after two years and go back to
being a receiver's coach but you know
this is a guy who's been around the nfl
a long time and it's good to see
something happened for maybe someone we
talked about this today sharing a guy
who maybe hasn't politicked and promoted
himself and tried to inject his name
into the discussion and he's just happy
to have a job and bust his butt and do
well and try to be part of a winner and
try to coach players and lead men and
mold young men into responsible adults
and he's not thinking i need to do this
this this i need to have this agent
who's going to be talking to media
people who will be positioning me to be
a head coach at some point i'm just
happy to be where i am and that's my
focus and that's been his focus for 26
years and and you know his ship has come
in and i think that part of it's a great
story
it is mike and and he said that to me
last night he said i was content with
being an assistant coach for my entire
career he also
built power for a couple years
coaches when you look at the a m staff
who we had with them gary kubiak mike
sherman uh some guys like that dennis
allen and uh aaron glenn both played on
that team so he's been around a lot of
great coaches in his career groomed
under them and if you notice all the
criticism is coming from people who
don't know him all the positivity is
coming from people who do know him and i
think he's going to be a very good head
coach now he's in an impossible
situation
the gremlins are invading again i think
the screen was about to go black always
wait for that moment when the screen
goes black we'll get shireen's
connection uh reestablished until then
let's hear from andy reid the coach of
the chiefs who was with david cully for
those 18 seasons here's reid from
earlier today on the traits that his
former assistant and right-hand man
david culley will bring to the houston
texans
yeah david will do a good job he he's a
he's a people person um he'll bring
energy to the building and
um
one of the most loyal guys i've ever
been around so he's just uh
he's a he's a great person i mean we
were together 18 years so you know it's
we had a few cheeseburgers together
every time i hear people person now i
think people person paper people the
jingle from the office commercial that
never was but uh yeah
reed also was conflicted
as it relates to what someone would have
asked as it relates to david culley
versus eric b enemy two of his
what one current one former
trusted assistants under consideration
for the job in houston cully ends up
getting it and uh i i just
it's going to be an interesting
experiment because this is clearly
outside the box this is a guy whose name
never came up for a head coaching job
never was a coordinator
anywhere and now he's a head coach and
i'm rooting for him i i'm ambivalent on
whether or not to root for an
organization that is so dysfunctional
and that it entrusted the keys to the
car to a guy who's unfit because i think
there are many other people in the nfl
who should have that job but i am
rooting for david culley
i have my texas jersey behind me mike
just for david collick because i'm
rooting for him too but it is a
dysfunctional franchise and again i
don't think they're going to win anytime
soon but i sure hope for david culley
that that he gets the chance to be there
long enough that we can see some wins
for that organization so you know he's a
great communicator he
commands a locker room and i think all
the players who played for him would
tell you that and we've seen some tweets
on
on twitter about that and and they all
respect him they'll play hard for him
again i don't know if they'll win or not
but you know it reminds me a little bit
of joe judge we didn't know much about
joe judge either when he went to the
giants and you saw that team play hard
for him and and they did all the right
things uh for the season but they were
still bad i mean i know they came close
to getting into the playoffs as the
nfc's champion but they were still a bad
team but it reminds me a little bit of
that situation mike kind of walk into a
situation where you don't know how he's
going to be as a head coach but i was
not surprised and i told david this that
he nailed the interviews because that's
what he does and he'll do the same thing
with his players he'll command that
respect for him and he's surrounding
himself with some former head coaches
which i think helps i expect romeo
cornell to stay there and lovey smith
coming in as defensive coordinator so he
has some guys with experience who've
done this that'll help
i i now fully appreciate how significant
this hire is to you that you would
obscure
the roger staubach jersey and you can
actually see the roblox roger staubach
jersey but but you didn't even take it
down it's like take that roger i'm
putting the texans jersey in front for
today because david culley is going to
be the coach of the texans you know
something i've heard from multiple
different people in the league the
belief that cully is going to be a short
time head coach of the texans as they
groom
josh mccown likely to be the
quarterbacks coach and likely to be the
successor to david culley whenever
this experiment ends whether it goes
five years ten years three years two
years have however many years there are
people who believe that's where it's
heading and it is believed that mccown
who interviewed for the head coaching
job will be the quarterback's coach and
they'll begin that process of getting
him ready to be the coach at some point
down the road shireen
and that's what happened in dallas you
know they they hired jason garrett
before they hired wade phillips and you
knew jason garrett was going to be the
next head coach of the cowboys even
though they didn't say it and that's
exactly what happened
2010 they fired wade phelps in the
middle of the season and jason garrett
got the job so not going to surprise me
that happens this likely is david
culley's last coaching job according to
elias he's the oldest first time head
coach ever in the nfl he's 65 years old
so however long this lasts i think it's
the end of his career but hopefully it
lasts a while and he can bring a
championship to the city of houston
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports